[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
my name is tony peacock robbie goodman
my name is sheila fry i am a 10-time
six-time two-time champ of the national
hollering contest of spy views corner
north carolina
hollering is a controlled sound that
farmers used to communicate with one
another before they had modern
conveniences like electricity or
telephones
hollers had a certain rhythm
and a modulation that would create an
echo that would travel over a long
distance
but there isn't just one type of hauler
there are actually four types of hollers
number one functional it serves a
purpose
[Music]
such as calling down to a field or
calling up from a field when you needed
something number two communicative
you're communicating a message such as
good morning good evening
number three distress
you need help
number four expressive just for sheer
fun
many times that could be in the form of
tunes or diddies
these types of hollers were what the
judges were looking for at the national
hollering contest
the first ever national hollering
contest was in 1969
it was started to raise funds for the
local fire department it became a
nationwide hit
hey that's me i wanted a junior to visit
in 1978
my hauler was a distress hauler it
sounded like a siren and i'm proud to be
a winner
everybody had their own twist that they
put on it
the national hollering contest ran for
about 48 years until 2015.
we created the
worldwide hollering festival that's
located in haute meals to try to
preserve and keep the tradition of
hollering alive
hollering is an important piece of
culture in this region because it helps
us remember our past
we can also appreciate the modern
conveniences we have today
hollering is part of simpler times and
it's just something that we need to
treasure because we need to know our
history
i love hollering because it brings the
community together
and just the fellowship that you have
with one another
we want to keep that tradition alive
[Music]
you